one of the games we've been wanting to
see more of least from my perspective is
quantum break so let's start right there
and they started off with like just
name-dropping just like drop in Shawn
Ashmore 80 Gillen little finger little
finger I prefer Carcetti but it you know
you got a lot dominic monaghan so like
really sort of leaning into that fact
like hey we've got stars in here we're
connecting this to the TV show guys
anyway big it's hard to be excited about
a TV show for a video game because we've
seen not a lot of great ones i mean it
always feels like this is gonna be
something that's tacked on but this is
one time when I I'm really excited for
the show like it looked really good it's
like all these characters from lost and
the story seems really interesting like
the other trailers have been leading up
to this and my god it's okay but like
now watching it in action and like this
weird time travel story it's like fringe
meets lost meets like I'm really excited
to learn more about this world and I
think we're living in a world where like
Netflix originals amazon originals
you're seeing like a diverse kind of
production quality of TV it's not just
some network shows and HBO making the
best TV out there like there is a lot of
creative talent being poured into a lot
of different channels hopefully this
ends up being one of them and when they
were talking about this game though they
were talking about it in a way that made
it sound like it was integrated into the
game that it wasn't really a standalone
TV show I don't know if we've heard
anything more about that but well we
haven't when they announced it they
initially were saying that they're going
to be elements of the TV show that like
the TV show will air and it'll be
something around the game but you'll be
able to play the game i think they are
initially announced that is episodic I
don't think that's I don't know if
that's the case anymore I can imagine
there would be sort of episodic content
you know you think to like halo 4 had
episodic content that came out and told
bits of a story so it's not hard to
imagine you know we they they time it
and that was timed weekly so you know if
they have weekly episodes airing of the
show then you have a weekly episode
maybe to play maybe it's like a DLC size
kind of thing it's a smaller mission but
you know the larger game itself larger
narrative is is a much more robust
experience yeah the sense i got of it
was something like halo 4 Spartan Ops
where you have like the you know the CGI
in this case would be live action
video going into then a short gameplay
mission that you apply each week and so
we did see some gameplay actually here
we're taking a look at exploring the
space where one of the first time it's
for the first sort of time travel
machine was built and it's doing this
neat thing that I i really like i think
is very cool is the sort of playing
through what like skipping through
different points in time it's a sort of
visually speed through this this history
of this project and but the interesting
thing was seeing this actually happen in
gameplay like I you know I sumo we're
notching now is more like not a
cinematic that this is something that's
just telling this story even when they
were showing gameplay if it's if it's
anything like that and I really hope
that the game does look like this it's
not kind of one of those BioShock
Infinite moments when it's like here's
an idea of what the aim is going to be
like but it doesn't quite pan out
because what it seemed like is like
you're at you're changing time while
you're playing you're gonna throw a time
bomb in like this area of the game these
people will be frozen and you'll be able
to fight that like you guys who are able
to manipulate that and not be affected
by it until you rip out their totten
like mini time-travel devices and they
freeze in mid air around you like that
that look really cool yeah I really like
the gameplay we're seeing it's sort of
it I don't know I don't know that we've
seen anything really like this where you
can still release top stuff and then go
after people maybe sort of seem there's
been some time dabbling in shooters
before first-person shooters like time
shift and others but this is I mean this
like the time thing is what elevates
this above another third person shooter
right like his I mean he was in cover
and he was like running around it kind
of has a vaguely uncharted look to it
it's otherwise it's very standard like
Oh get behind cover dodge guys you can
see where the bullets are coming from
mhmmm what I was thinking those like you
know it does look very powerful this
time ability which actually in a sense
contextualizes why you're this one one
man army in a sense you know what a lot
of games you are just one guy going
through you know murdering tons and tons
of soldiers but in this you actually
have some sort of story context for that
if you can do all this weird time crap
of course you're gonna be like a super
dude but yeah I do like this part they
showed up with these soldiers who are
not who are immune to the time stuff and
so that will sort of it's another
wrinkle in that layered sort of system
and then I liked how when you killed
them they stay frozen time they lost
their ability to be out of
I'm and so I think that like certainly
in the demo setting they are doing a
pretty good job of showcasing some of
the cool facets of the time manipulation
in quantum break I guess remains to be
seen how that ends up playing out
quantum break is coming out april fifth
in 2016 and presumably the TV show is
going to be right along with that it's
kind of core to the experience i'd
imagine yeah